I have always been a huge proponent of
the systems thinking philosophy and one
of my strongest beliefs has always been
that confusion is a result of a lack of
integration of Parts within thinking
systems we become confused because
something is missing or because
something doesn't feel right the
Symphony of interconnected parts that
gives rise to complexity is not in tune
with our awareness and as a result The
Melody of our world becomes distorted
humans don't like Distortion or at least
we are not programmed to like it our
role is to become maestros of our part
of the world and orchestrate the right
Symphony we can't really become maestros
of the whole world because the whole
world is beyond our scope of
understanding and the symphony becomes
too vast when the symphony becomes too
vast it feels like a mishmash of chaotic
elements and we end up floating in a
notion of far-fetched possibilities and
opportunities nobody likes to float
aimlessly nobody likes to feel lost